hello everyone and welcome to vlog
university now for those of you who are
new to the show and aren't quite sure
what vlog university is I created this
because one of the top questions that I
get is Justine I want to make videos but
I don't know what to make videos about
so each week I give you guys a topic and
for your homework assignment you create
a video on that topic and submit it here
as a video response to this video the
last episode was a pirate-themed video
now you guys created so many hilarious
videos that it was really hard to choose
just a few to feature now these next two
videos were probably some of my
favorites and I'm not gonna lie it's
mostly because there were definitely
some cute animals involved
all right matey your task is to go
pillage and plunder and bring back booty
and treasure for a reward this next
video is by the real Nick Bravo now if I
were a casting director casting for the
next bar to the Caribbean movie I'm
pretty sure he would be my first choice
so that was a little awkward at UPS just
showed up at my door and I'm gonna open
the door you just see an apartment full
of lighting and camera equipment and
that probably makes someone wonder
what's going on in there
why are just a lot that are patch you
sods you you know what to say
that's are they after your booty those
pirate themed episode wouldn't be quite
complete without an interview with a
pirate let's take a peek at Andy eight
B's interviewing tactics it's pretty
good rated R I just destroyed this whole
set say to me how do you feel you steal
people's money now there's one thing
that I have noticed here on YouTube is
there's a lot of extremely artistic
people now just don't mess up your name
Tara zero to one eight awesome drew us a
picture of a pirate
now not only to give so many artistic
people here on YouTube we have a lot of
musically gifted people check out this
sweet video by mr. pint glass
now if you ever wondered what fred would
be like if you were a pirate ha well
don't worry we've found the answer and
it's this video right here right stick
stands and a great thank you but not
good not good enough sterling now for
the fun part your homework assignment
for the next episode is fancy probably
wondering just seeing what the heck are
you talking about fancy well you fancy
what type of fancy videos am I looking
for
I'm not actually sure it's up to your
interpretation you could just use the
word fancy in a video you could show us
how to be fancy or you could just um
yeah I'll leave that one up to you guys
thanks so much for watching and creating
such amazing videos you guys are super
talented and I look forward to seeing
what you guys come up with for the fancy
episode yeah don't forget to click
Subscribe so that you'll know when I
have a new video and be sure to check
out all of my other YouTube channels I
also have a new channel iJustine gaming
because I have recently become addicted
to playing xbox so I'm gonna be starting
to post gameplay videos and I don't
really know what else but we're gonna
find out I'm gonna find out together
so thanks again I'm gonna stop rambling
and good luck I love you I will see you
soon